what's going on guys this is Rob and if
you're enjoying the content here on my
channel then make sure you hit the like
button and make sure you hit subscribe
so you can't decide what direction the
content on my channel goes in in the
foreseeable future
what's going on guys this is Rob and
welcome back to our episode on how to
kill superheroes however before we start
a few updates for you guys if you look
on the main page here on my youtube
channel you will notice you will notice
you will almost said no you will notice
that I have updated the playlist and
stuff and so what I've done is I've
broken it down in an easier to
understand way the first little section
is stuff that I'm covering right now at
the moment so you'll find Amazing
Spiderman you'll find our injustice
videos you'll find how to kill
superheroes and you will find the Green
Lantern those will change as we finish
stories and start new ones the other
section is to help you guys sort out
through all your stuff if you're new to
comic book so if you'll find DC rebirth
you'll find DC rebirth sorted by heroes
you'll find all-new all-different marvel
you'll find only well different Marvel
sorted by heroes you'll find our
character discussions all that kind of
good stuff and then after that it just
breaks down with the playlist
everybody's seem to dig the most which
is like The Incredible Hulk chronology
and all that kind of good stuff I think
maybe Omega and Beyond omegal know the
Omega and beyond all of them omega-level
mutant that is in the new to comic book
section so anyway guys I yeah what is up
we are back with our video series on how
to kill superheroes and today we are
going to focus on the character of Wally
West we are murderous Bunch
when it comes to the idea of kill a
super heroes I don't know we like
killing them so much but we love killing
them however at this point you're
probably asking yourself raah haven't we
already covered the flash on this
particular series called how to kill
superheroes which you can find every
Wednesday here on my channel and you
would be right and asking that question
but as I mentioned in that video we were
discussing the flash on a very
superficial level and what I mean is
that we were basically dealing with the
flash as a concept and we figured out
ways to kill any generic speedster in
the DC Universe what I also said in that
video is that we would return to the
subject of the flash by looking at some
of the individuals who have borne the
moniker of the flash throughout the
history of DC Comics and today I make
good on that promise as we turn our
attention to perhaps the fastest and
most powerful flash ever wally west now
before we go any further it's important
to note that we are talking about the
original or pre flashpoint version of
wally west not the new 52 version of
Wally's currently fighting crime in DC
rebirth and the team
and the flash the distinction that this
is pre flashpoint Wally West has even
greater significance than just telling
him which of the two persons of Wally
that exists within DC that we're
referring to
it also lets us know what power set
we're dealing with now what I mean is
that prior to the flashpoint event that
rebooted the entire DC universe and
temporarily wiped Wally from existence
Wally had a power that set him apart
from all other speedsters now following
the rebirth event that brought Wally
back to the main line continuity we
haven't really seen much differentiation
between Wally and Barry Allen as far as
their powers go since they'd basically
been written to be almost identical in
terms of their abilities but for this
video we're going to assume that Wally's
able to pull off all of the feats that
we saw him before
prior to flashpoint because there are
some things that he could do that none
of the other flashes had ever been able
to accomplish but that being said let's
do what we always do and let's jump
right into his powers so the most
notable and most obvious of all powers
of the speedsters is the SuperSpeed they
derived from the energy known as the
Speed Force along with superhuman
reflexes agility durability and stamina
speedsters also have the ability to
phase through objects by vibrating fast
enough that their molecules pass through
spaces between the molecules of that
particular object they can also generate
enough static electricity to produce
Speed Force lightning which they can
manipulate and throw at opponents
furthermore because of their connection
to the Speed Force speedsters are able
to regenerate from injuries at an
insanely fast rate now let's go into
some of the stuff that's actually
interesting
what are the powers and abilities unique
to Wally West first of all
Wally's able to perform the infinite
mass punch which he achieves by
traveling at near light speed and
gaining so much relative mass that he's
able to land a punch that has a force
greater than a white dwarf star now when
he performed the infinite mass punch he
was able to hit a super-powered white
Martian from Mount Rushmore in South
Dakota to the middle of the African
savannah with one blow now as far as how
this makes Wally tougher to kill this is
a crazy powerful offensive weapon that
he can use to pretty much remove us from
the battlefield and possibly
incapacitate or even kill us therefore
we're likely going to have to go into
battle with some means of counteracting
the effects of the infinite mass punch
which is easier said than done unless we
somehow have the ability to become
intangible so that the punch goes right
through us
we're going to have to find some
material to absorb the energy generated
by the infinite mass clenched itself the
key is finding a metal that exists in
the DC universe and the closest thing
that I've been able to find is a metal
known as volatile promethium which makes
up the measure armor worn by Deathstroke
and has among its properties the ability
to absorb almost limitless amounts of
energy now whether or not this would be
sufficient to absorb the force of Wally
West punch we can't say for sure but it
seems to be our best bet and negating
the punches effects however we have to
be careful when using this material as
it's been shown to have unitive effects
on human physiology which Deathstroke is
able to overcome due to his healing
factor but since we don't have a healing
factor we're probably going to have to
come up with a way to kill Wally before
he can land BM for the mass punch in the
first place
now that proposition is made even more
difficult by another of Wally West's
powers the ability to steal the speed of
other people and objects rendering them
unable to move what this means is that
Wally can take a speed from other super
fast individuals and objects moving at
high speeds such as bullets or moving
vehicles and due to Wally's close
connection with the Speed Force he's
able to extend this ability to the
entire planet now the two exceptions to
this ability seem to be professor zoom
who uses the negative Speed Force and
Barry Allen since Barry was the one who
created the Speed Force in the first
place finally we come to another power
distinct - Wally which is the ability to
use the Speed Force to create solid
constructs that he can use in a variety
of ways including an Armour that allows
him to run even when his legs have been
broken so even if we are able to
overcome Wally's and same durability and
regenerative healing factor and deal
significant damage to him we still have
to deal with the possibility that he'll
be able to use the Speed Force to
construct a suit of armor that will
allow him to continue in battle so the
last time we did this video we killed
the flash by luring him into an airplane
and detonating a bomb in the hopes that
the explosion would kill him
instantaneously however I'm not sure
that's going to be a viable option when
it comes to Wally West because he's
actually so fast that he's able to
perceive things so quickly that time
seems to stand still so as soon as the
bomb started to explode Wally would be
able to hear it and exit the plane
before he was caught up in the explosion
now one reason for using the plane as a
device to kill the flash was so that he
would have nowhere to run
once he got away from the explosion
Wally is able to circumvent the strategy
in its entirety as he's been shown to be
able to fly
do something similar to fly by spinning
himself at ultra-fast speeds so the
question becomes how can we kill the
fastest man alive with all the powers
that we've shown so far well one way
would be to gain access to the negative
speed force those guys we don't know the
negative speed force is exactly what it
sounds like a counterbalance to the
speed force which gives the Flash's
powers and it functions as a cancerous
source that will destroy the Speed Force
should one of the speedsters that rely
on the Speed Force for power come into
contact with the negative Speed Force
their connection would be blocked
therefore depriving them of their powers
the problem with this is that the
negative Speed Force was created by
Professor zoom and it's unclear how
someone can tap into it so we would
likely have to enlist the help of zoom
in order to shut off Wally's powers and
this in and of itself is a dangerous
gambit simply because of the fact the
professor zoom would probably betray us
after we beat Wally so to be honest with
you guys I think that eating away the
Speed Force is really the only possible
way we have of killing Wally and the
reason I say this is that Wally's
connection to the Speed Force is the
strongest of all the flashes and he
can't simply be cut off from it so if he
can't be cut off from the Speed Force
the only way to power him down is to
actually destroy the Speed Force using
the negative Speed Force and really we
have no choice but to power Wally down
because I don't think if full power
there's any way that he can actually be
killed he's simply too fast to take my
surprise and he would anticipate
perceive and instantaneously react to
anything we tried to do and there's
absolutely no way that we would ever
catch him if he tried to run away from
our attack as Wally is generally
believed to be the fastest of the
flashes with that being said we're going
to bring this video to an end if you
guys are new here to come and to explain
make sure you guys have the sub button
to become part of the report if you guys
enjoyed this video make sure you drop a
like and yeah I will catch you guys on
it
peace no here's something we hope you'll
really like
Oh what's not setting up for show we're
getting ready to do say hello what does
that know I'm recording oh shut up and
play with the this is Chris or local
sexy stud hey what's up really say I am
I'm a sexy man oh yeah I don't
don't you know classifier exterior side
me into anything hey dude look okay if I
looked like I would be like yeah all
right so tell people where you're
working with here what do you know
forgetting the 78 6500 hooked up on a
carbon fiber slider with a carbon fiber
tripod rode micro and screen Wow
okay you ready oh yeah is it uh really
gonna be able to showing off your belly
oh I'm better I'm not a better all right
we're good microphone down in there yeah
he's gonna be able to pick it up yeah
she was like it up this is it on your
chest or is it I mean I hope getting a
very tip like where you got yours okay
cool
no all right now here's the deal I guess
my plan where's that it should be a
beating Carla you just know what a
totally covered but we should have no
problem to it whether right now okay
what am i key to Holly's good um are we
hooking it okay we're going into those
okay well then let me hook mine up and
then I'll do an audio test real quick
and make sure at the time doing right
now
there you go Dylan thanks amber that'll
put your thing on again
check check check the muck why don't I
know cannot we drop a book that beat
this you know us that's what people do
stuff
line up that's a new move any shirtless
oh wow having trouble it's so portable
wrong but he's going to be a lot of
trying this arms up of unit I was which
is a brand but don't you know deli
I have Adonis a flicker and thinking
should I know or dawn currently you're
spending all your gonna put it on yet I
miss barrace overhead it'll dinner
paying a twenty guy in the shirt better
better home sweet home usually hold it
down time to flatten our rules we do you
rule as the point is the man
Oh
[Music]